we live in a world where filmmakers have
lost their imagination so of course
there's going to be another big
hollywood reboot but what this time
of course
flash gordon
welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
so producer john davis has been trying
to make a reboot of the flash gordon
original comics for quite some time he
wanted to make an animated movie and has
had a couple of very high profile
directors
in line to do this matthew vaughn and
julie savory are both big budget
hollywood directors and at different
times they've both been signed on to do
this film
but now they've moved on and taika
waititi is now writing and in line to
direct
not an animated movie
but a live action big budget film
now
this is how basically happened because
taika ytt was asked if he would mind
writing this because they were you know
really struggling to make the project
work he got stuck in mainly because of
his love for the original movie he said
when he was a kid it was one of his
favorite films and to be honest if you
watch thor ragnarok you can really see
the obvious inspiration when he got
stuck into it though and started writing
the script he realized this didn't
really work as an animated movie he
wanted to do it as a live-action film so
he got onto the phone he called john
davis he said come on man we need to
make this live action and john davis's
reaction was oh hell yeah
takawatiti is kind of the man in
hollywood at the moment everything he
touches really pretty much turns to gold
and really he completely reinvigorated
the thor franchise with ragnarok
but
this is a quite a dangerous franchise
it's it's quite a difficult thing to get
your head around and to get right i can
see the dangers of this film and this
film going
very very wrong
we only have to look at sci-fi channels
attempt to reboot this a few years ago
to know that this really can become a
very cheesy character really quickly if
you let it
take awaytiti is the man to do this he
really is the man to get this the
balance between the the cheesiness the
humor the adventure and the the real
gritty realism that we're gonna want
from this this franchise because if you
really think about the flash gordon
movie
it's about
earth getting attacked obviously by ming
the merciless
um and one man other than being a bit of
a sport hero has really nothing about
him he's not particularly bright he's
not particularly special in lots of
different ways he can throw a ball far
and that's about it
but in the face of danger he steps up
and he inspires
the entire planet of [ __ ] to turn
against ming
now we live in quite a fractured society
at the moment
wouldn't it be amazing for somebody like
flash gordon to step up and inspire us
to come together
this is the kind of movie that i
actually think could be quite inspiring
it could be more than just a really
colourful adventure in space it could
actually reflect a lot of things in
society now that we wish we could change
and i always love that in sci-fi when
it's more than just
one layered film action movie whenever
you know there's more to it
i already know what people are going to
say they're going to make it woke
they're going to make it flash jennifer
or something that sounds wrong but it
sounds like an adult movie but anyway um
i i don't think that's a risk with this
film
the male role in this as as flash gordon
isn't necessarily like the traditional
hero even though yes okay he's a jock
um and he's you know he's the sports
star sort of thing he's he has his flaws
um and it's even maybe even because of
his flaws that he succeeds rather than
his physical ability in lots of ways
but also in this film there are already
big female characters even flash
gordon's love interest dale arden
okay she runs around a lot and gets
captured a lot and everybody falls in
love with her and everyone's trying to
sleep with her all the time and you know
but her character through the arc of the
comics in particular grew massively in
the first couple of comics she didn't
even say a word but by the end of it she
was assisting she was growing as a
scientist
her importance was growing in defending
the earth you know and even though she
continued to get captured every five
minutes flash gordon could save her her
character grew and she become an actual
really important strong female role and
i'm going to say
this is a this is a movie like all of
these films from back in the 60s 70s 80s
will need modernizing and no no again i
know a lot of people can say why why
does it need to be changed it needs to
be changed because we have a modern
audience expectations are different
society is different we're talking about
strong female characters you've got
princess aura now she's merciless
daughter and she is at times ruthless
but she turns against and stands up to
her dad she does fall in love with flash
gordon and she does try to thwart dale
constantly
but she is a strong female character she
stands up for what she wants that that
little love triangle there is a really
interesting plot
and something that i actually saw taiko
ytt will really enjoy exploring and then
you've got general kala
who is a complete
i mean you want to talk about strong
female characters this chick is a nutter
she is completely ruthless
um she is obviously
top of the military the generally within
the military she is intelligent
beautiful and you know completely evil
she's a brilliant character and again
you're talking about this who's being
woken changing genders or doing it else
you don't need to
you've got incredibly strong female
characters
we might need to update what they're
wearing a little bit because in the
movie they do wander around in bejeweled
bikinis quite a lot we've moved on from
that unfortunately
i like seeing women in bikinis i just do
but we've moved on from that in big
hollywood movies
correctly so so you know we'll see a
little bit more of respect towards the
female genders talking about clothing
though what brian blessed was wearing
was basically
leather armor wings and hot pants
um so maybe we need a bit more respect
towards the male characters as well
i don't need to see brian bliss's legs
so when is this likely to happen well
takeaway tt has got several other
projects on the go at the moment as i
say he really is the man in hollywood at
the moment um he has is a new project
called next goal wins he's then got thor
love and thunder he's then got an
unnamed star wars project he's directing
this will come after those so we're
probably not talking until you know
maybe two years down the line until we
actually see this in theaters but i do
think
he's writing it now
it's basically green lit already um
anything that takes he puts his name to
at the moment is going to get greenlit
so this is going to happen it's just a
matter of how quickly he can get to it
and but who might star in it who is
going to be a flash gordon well
obviously the rumors are already around
chris hemsworth obviously the
relationship between taikawatiti and
chris hensworth thanks to the thor
movies they're they're really they are
really good friends
there's always going to be those rumors
i'd maybe like to see somebody a bit
younger play the flash gordon roll i'd
like to see him you know as a as a
coming out of college um quarterback
maybe is it maybe he's a failed
quarterback um something like that i
think christine was maybe a little bit
older ready and the other name being
thrown around is chris evans um and i
think he's that's the same thing but
saying that
chris henderson would be amazed in this
role he's brilliant in everything and i
honestly he probably would be the
perfect flash gordon what are the big
challenges for this role i've already
mentioned this film it really is at risk
of becoming cheesy if you let it it's
one of those things that's so big so
colorful
it can get away from you really easily
and um i think takaotiti's got the skill
to not let it go too far he did that in
ragnarok he pushed right up to the line
of ridiculous but he never crossed it
and that's why that movie is so
brilliant
he's also got that talent of getting the
music right which i think is a massive
part of when you're doing something
that's very big and very sort of at risk
of becoming stupid
the right music can just tone it and
keep it that this side of sensible that
it doesn't get too ridiculous a really
big challenge is how do you match up to
the original movie because you've got
characters like brian blessed prince
volta
and iconic moments like flash gordon's
alive and paying homage to the movie
without again crossing that line into
cheesy
is a big ask
but i honestly think taika ytt is the
man
to answer that question and to make a
movie that we will all really really
love and honestly i cannot wait
for a flash gordon reboot this is one of
those films that's screaming out for a
modern version and i can't wait
so if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification really helps us out you can
join the channel and see all of our
videos 24 hours before everybody else
and it also really helps me to make new
content and supports the channel
you can also go and join us on facebook
the link is in the description
so
please stay safe and i will see you next
time
[Music]